you've had a great career and I'm
curious if someone has never seen
anything you've done before what is the
first thing you'd like them watching and
why oh that's a great question Steve God
I love that
I'm
um I think I really feel so proud of the
movie I did with Chris Kelly called
other people it's very dramatic I play
the mom dying of cancer but it's funny
and I I won the independent Spirit award
for that so I really feel so proud of
that movie or maybe Superstar too
because that's so close to my heart 100
um early in your career you did an
episode of Twin Peaks which was like
before you made you know when right at
the beginning do you remember your
experience on that set and how thrilling
it was to get a part I was so thrilled
and I I actually wrote about this in my
Memoir my friend and I couldn't get in
the door to get a break so we made up
this scam that we said we worked for
David Mamet and we would make calls for
one another pretending to be agents or
people that you know pretending to be
people that worked with David Mammon and
we were recommending these young kid
actors who we thought were brilliant and
we just made up this whole story to get
in the door and I really wanted to be on
Twin Peaks so I said to my young friend
Gene can you call
um the casting director Joanna Ray and
get me in because I really want to be on
Twin Peaks so he called doing the scam
saying this is Arnold Katz calling from
David mammoth's office we have this
young girl Molly who we really believe
in we'd love for you to meet her and
Joanna Ray was like I would love to meet
Molly and so so we got in under that and
then I met her and she said I really
want you to meet David you know I really
want you to meet David and you'd be so
great on the show so I got cast on the
show through the scam and as a happy
helping hand ladies so and it was
directed by Caleb Deschanel it was like
one of my first big parts and I couldn't
believe it because I would drive by
Joanna Ray's office and kind of where
they were shooting and I was like oh I
really want to be on Twin Peaks so I
kind of visualized it isn't that wild
first of all it's insane because you
could never do that today I don't think
you know yeah no no we kind of knew that
there was no cross-checking with Dave
David Mamet so we thought oh I don't
know we knew that he was more he wasn't
coming to California too much so people
didn't didn't have like a close
relationship with him but they were such
fans of his so we could get into any you
know a lot of different offices jumping
into why I get to talk to you um yeah
trying to portray addiction realistic
Addiction on screen can be like touching
the third rail because if it doesn't
work it's just bad but Zach did such a
great job with this what was it like for
you reading the script for the first
time and seeing the way he was really
trying to present this in an authentic
and real way I really liked it because I
think that you know if anybody who I who
I who I have known who's gone through
struggling with a loved one with
addiction it's such a hard roller
coaster ride where you feel powerless
and you you can be like an enabler you
try tough love and nothing's working
people just don't know what to do they
feel so helpless so I thought it was
very realistic in that way and then
she's also a mother and she doesn't want
her daughter to die and she's scared so
she's like oh she gets to a very low
point where she's such an enabler that
she she goes oh here honey here's pills
just we'll figure it out we'll just take
these and because she she doesn't want
her to disappear again or it's too scary
and I mean I I watch that show
intervention so I feel like I love it
and it really helps you understand the
whole like it's a family disease it's
the codependence with the addiction and
very hard and and I I love saying the
author Sam Quinones and I read a lot of
his books and I've read Dreamland and I
like reading about the crisis and I'm
fascinated with it I read a lot about it
during my free time because I find it
interesting what was your reaction when
you found out you were going to be and I
rarely say this but getting to do a
scene with Morgan Freeman it was oh my
gosh it was so fantastic Steve I felt
like it was a dream I actually couldn't
believe I was in the scene with him that
it was hard to concentrate it almost
felt like feeling like
I'm doing my lines but in my head I'm
like I'm in a scene with Morgan Freeman
it felt like being in an amusement park
and going up on like uh like up a roller
coaster like up up here we go it kind of
felt like that like you know just like
absolutely thrilling and he's very kind
and um
so professional and everything you would
want him to be and there was a moment
where we had a little break and they
were fixing the lights and I said I have
to tell you I'm pinching myself I can't
believe I'm in a scene with you and he
he was just so nice and he just smiled
and was just so sweet and this is a
really funny story Steve I actually my
daughter and I went to the wax museum in
Hollywood and I took pictures with the
Morgan Freeman wax figure
and I told him and he was like that's
funny so I was trying to find I think I
showed I think I showed him the picture
so it was really funny I like learning
about the behind the scenes the making
of a show or a movie
um is there anything that you think
would surprise people to learn about the
making of a good person
um anything that would surprise me to
learn about what makes a good person
yeah it's maybe I worded it bad but like
uh you know anything unique to this
shoot or anything that like you know a
fan of the movie might be you know
interested to learn oh yeah I think
um let's see here well I think the path
to you know if you go through something
hard and you feel like you made a
terrible mistake and you're a good
person
I think the path to forgive oneself can
be a really rocky road and people can be
so hard on themselves and but there are
good people who make mistakes and I
think um you have to have compassion for
others and compassion for yourself and
hopefully if you can get through that
you can come out of the other end a
better person you know and and maybe
find forgiveness for yourself and
Redemption and so I think the movie does
a good job of showing that and and then
Morgan Freeman writes a letter at the
end talking about embracing your fate
and and that that that those ideas
there's a scene of you outside
Florence's bedroom picture like you're
clearly been drinking uh and you are
pitching her on why you guys should do
shark tank when you're filming a scene
like that how much is that exactly what
Zach wrote and how much is that like a
mix of you getting to add a little bit
of yourself that's a great question it's
definitely Zach's idea of like you're
gonna pitch your shark tank but then he
lets me be very loose with it and I'm
drinking and so I have to be loose with
it because she's like that'll be so fun
so it was um he pitched me a couple
ideas you could say this or that or this
like a couple different Shark Tank ideas
so I he he let me really kind of
improvise that be pretty loose because
she's kind of drunk and she's like you
know the daughter's in the room doing
drugs and I'm out there in my own world
with my Pinot Grigio sauvignon blanc and
you know I'm I'm using wine the way she
uses drugs I have my own little release
to numb out and that no no need to stop
I'm just gonna say seriously congrats on
the movie and um good luck with the rest
of your speed dating today